yeah it's a pleasure to be here uh
welcome to my talk i'm going to be
speaking about um causal inference on
digital platforms
and um
the broader framing for this talk is
that there are all these causal stories
about algorithmic moderation on social
platforms that i'm sure you've heard you
know all these terms like filter bubbles
eco chambers political polarization
radicalization amplification and
misinformation all these things and if
you think about it and that's relevant
for this workshop these are all uh what
are called causal stories right they
stipulate that there's some kind of
mechanism at play some kind of dynamic
mechanism by which some kind of
algorithmic curation or moderation leads
to some um you know social outcome that
we're concerned with right and so uh
these are urgent problems they're
fiercely debated uh uh you know uh today
and uh what's uh worrisome and that is
that in many cases we have very limited
sort of theoretical understanding uh
about these phenomena and also very
limited empirical information of like
you know uh how they occur and where
they occur
um
so
i'm not gonna uh you know uh solve all
these issues in this talk instead i'll
tell you sort of about two projects i
did at twitter which uh maybe stand in
for uh this broader set of problems that
i'm interested in okay so um here are
the two projects one of them is
algorithmic amplification of politics on
twitter um appeared on pns earlier this
year uh as was led by a friend suzar
sofia iraqitina conor bryant luca belly
andrew schleicher
andy schleicher
who were all at twitter at the time
um so friends did you know the bulk of
the work and this is
uh is um you know uh
put in a whole lot of effort i'm mostly
just reporting on these uh interesting
findings and the other project was uh
done by smitha millie and luca belly um
or during work with them on causal
inference and how it sort of fails to
um you know or struggle with um you know
human agency on online platforms and
i'll talk about these two projects and
how they're related and how they give
you sort of a sense of what the broader
challenges are for applying causal
inference to social platforms and the
issues you're going to run into okay
um and this is uh based on you know some
time i spend at twitter between 2019 and
2021 um and work i did there okay so
feel free to stop me if there are any
questions uh it's probably gonna be a
relatively short talk i'm not gonna
spend all the 40 minutes so there should
be some discussion
okay so um let's start with twitter's
home timeline okay so i told you these
are projects that were done at twitter
when you open up twitter um you probably
see uh tweets like these um you know how
many of you use twitter this is an
academic crowd probably okay there's
like some reporting bias here people
don't want to you know out themselves
but i feel like everyone probably has a
secret twitter account and is checking
uh checking stuff um and so the home
timeline is what you see when you log on
so when you either use the web interface
or the the you know what is it the cell
phone client you see like a stream of
tweets
and um this stream of tweets has been
per like personally or sort of
algorithmically ranked on a personalized
manner since 2016. so in 2016 twitter
announced a big change by which they
were going to
re-rank or algorithmically rank uh your
uh you know home timeline based on some
machine learning model okay trained uh
trained on various signals various uh
data sources and it's really sort of
like the kitchen sync approach to these
problems like the way you would expect
it you sort of throw in all the signals
you have
and you try to like get some kind of uh
relevant ranking okay and so before that
it was basically a reverse chronological
ordering so you'd see the most recent
tweets first from the people you
followed um plus some filtering so they
were even like on the reverse
chronological timeline there's some
algorithms at play but it's not really
like a machine learning thing or it's
like less of a machine learning thing
than the personalized uh ranking that uh
has been there since 2016. okay and ever
since there has been like an intense
debate about the effects of algorithmic
ranking and algorithmic moderation on on
twitter right and who benefits from it
and who's silenced by it and what's
going on especially in the political
context okay so who is benefiting from
the algorithmic timeline um you know
2016 you know was a uh you know a lot of
political events obviously unfolded and
um you know there has been a lot of uh
you know discussion on like what this
algorithmic timeline did to sort of the
political conversation on twitter
there was an interesting article in the
economist like a year and a half ago
that ran an experiment
where they looked at tweets by donald
trump
and they compared how well these tweets
were faring on reverse chronological
timelines
uh compared with algorithmically ranked
timelines
and they found that um you know actually
actually the algorithmic ranking did not
uh seem to sort of suppress tweets by
donald trump or even de-amplify them
anyway but it did sort of respond to
what they said were sort of more
inflammatory tweets so they found that
the the algorithmic timeline seemed to
like sort of emphasize or highlight
re-rank
um you know things that were more uh
emotional or inflammatory
no they just monitor they said like an
account so twitter lets you opt out of
the algorithmic timeline so they set up
multiple accounts one with a reverse
chronological timeline and one with like
the algorithmic timeline and then they
just looked at what they saw so they
would log on with both accounts and they
would just count basically it was a
little bit anecdotal like small data but
it was an interesting uh interesting
idea okay there's lots of other research
on like this claim that you know
conservatives are silenced um and
there's also much research on like the
differences between like uh you know how
different political parties use twitter
so there's a lot of uh you sort of um
uh or growing understanding that
different political actors utilize
twitter differently and sort of um you
know for for their own purpose to
strategize on it differently okay so um
we wanted to know uh sort of you know
does algorithmic personalization cause
an advantage uh along established
political lines does it favor the right
or the left or more radical positions
more central positions um who actually
benefits from this okay
and what we um used for uh you know
addressing this question or getting some
insights on it was an experimental setup
that started on twitter in 2016 that was
set up by the um you know home timelines
team at twitter
and um wisely they when they set up this
new algorithmic timeline they set aside
a control group of one percent of all
global users that were reversed that
were assigned like a reverse
chronological timeline so one percent of
twitter users are seeing a reverse
chronological timeline possibly without
knowing it um and i like to think that
some people who complain about the
algorithm are in the control group um
but um
you know that's that's the control group
and the treatment group was like another
set of four percent of all global users
randomly assigned
um to the algorithmically ranked group
that's just the same treatment that
everyone gets so basically think of like
the treatment group as everyone except
for the control group but for some
technical purposes they're like the
treatment group is a subsample of of all
users
okay and obviously twitter um you know
was interested in this kind of setup to
sort of monitor the algorithmic timeline
for product improvement see how well
certain things are working it's like
engagements going up on the algorithmic
timeline or or down so they're
monitoring various metrics um you know
based on this randomized experiment okay
um so if you think about this kind of
setup right as like causal inference
experts there are a few things you'll
notice right away that make this like a
little bit of a an idiosyncratic setup
one of them is of course that you have
lots of network effects that's kind of
unavoidable
so people interact in particular what's
you know notable is that
the control group still sees mostly
content written by non-control users so
if you have a reverse chronological
timeline you're still seeing like you
know tweets authored by people who
consume an algorithmically ranked
timeline so in a sense you're still like
experiencing indirect effects of
algorithmic curation and moderation okay
so that's like sort of a an effect
that's at play
whether you want these network effects
or not depends on what question you want
to answer right sometimes the network
effects is exactly what you care about
sometimes you would sort of like to uh
you know
um have an effect that that sort of is
um gets rid of these effects okay
um the other thing that's sort of
annoying a little bit is that the
treatment changes over time okay so the
algorithmic timeline of course is
subject to like a lot of refinement and
tweaking and improvements and so twitter
continues to update the algorithm all
the time and so it's not like one
constant treatment it's not the same
treatment okay so the people that are in
the treatment group do get algorithmic
updates it's not like the product is
frozen in time
um and that's also true for the control
group okay so even the control group
changes over time for instance when it
comes to things like safety filters
right so things like you know
suppressing abusive content things that
twitter considers a matter of safety
that they will also do unlike the
control group okay and so yeah as i said
twitter used the experimental setup for
tweaking the platform so there's kind of
like an effect here whereby
measurements on this like uh you know uh
control group um feed into updates to
the treatment okay so it's it's a little
bit of a
um thingy so like you know measurements
at time t influence treatment at time t
plus one okay
so what you get from this kind of
experiment is what i call hodgepodge
causal effects um which is first of all
it is a causal effect of sorts because
you break randomization you break
confounding through randomization you
still randomize so there's like no way
that something like uh you know
influenced assignment into controller
treatment group okay but
um on top of that all mediators are at
play sort of all mechanisms that you can
imagine on the platform are
simultaneously at play okay and this is
what i call the hodgepodge so all the
network and all the network effects are
active
how well different actors strategically
respond to the algorithmic timeline is
an important effect like you know
there's people who see how this thing
works and will like adapt to it
and then there's a twitter's own
optimizations based on the setup okay so
the picture is something like this there
are network effects so you have to sort
of talk about treatment to user i and
outcome for user i you break confounding
so there's no possible way that like
there's some kind of variable x that
influences both treatment for user eye
and outcome for user eye but there are
all sorts of different mechanisms right
and these different mechanisms these
different mediators do have different
political moral and sociological
significance right it depends on what
question you want to answer if you want
to say that you know twitter did
something wrong you might be interested
in one particular mechanism if you want
to say something else then uh you know
you might be interested in a different
mechanism okay so this is something that
in this talk will like lump together so
the numbers are going to see sort of all
all mediators at play simultaneously
okay so what we ended up measuring is a
notion called algorithmic amplification
okay so let me tell you what algorithmic
amplification is
um it's a property of a set of tweets
with respect to a set of users and we
defined something called the
amplification ratio
and it's just the number of treatment
users in you who encountered a tweet
in the set t
divided by the number of control users
in the set of users you who encountered
a tweet in t so it's roughly the
exposure that you're uh that the tweets
and tee are getting
uh among the users you're in treatment
divided normalized by the exposure that
the tweets are getting
um
in the control group within you okay as
an example you could take you and this
is
usually how we instantiate this we take
you to be let's say all german twitter
users okay
t is all the tweets uh you know sent by
some uh you know politicians of some
particular political party in this case
you know let's say cdu or some german
party and some time window and the time
window of our study was actually april
1st 2020 through august 15 2020. so we
generally look at tweets in that range
and we vary this like set of users by
like uh particular countries
and we vary the set of tweets by like
you know different politicians different
news sources different parties and so on
okay
do you actually mean
traction of users
good catch so yeah so um so as i said
the treatment group's like four times as
large as like the control group so if
you just divide you would get like weird
numbers so we actually like divide you
know normalize and and and subtract a
little bit so that
zero percent um is equal is equal
proportion okay
so um
you know an amplification ratio of zero
percent corresponds to a random user uh
from treatment is just as likely to see
a tweet and t as a random user in
control okay so this is kind of how i
want you to interpret this
so what's your like if you're in
treatment how likely are you to go to
see a tweet nt compared with when you're
in control okay
there's also a technical issue here for
like what it means to see a tweet right
um and what we're counting our so-called
linger impressions
um that's a um a technical term for like
a tweet that was visible on your screen
by more than half for more than some
number of milliseconds okay so there's
some technical definition and it's like
what twitter considers to be like an
actual impression like not just you
didn't just like scroll over it but
somehow you lingered on it and there's
like some kind of evidence that you
actually perceived it okay
um
so yeah so generally amplification ratio
zero means uh same and treatment and
control
50 means like treatment is getting like
a 50 advantage and seeing the tweet 100
is like twice as likely and so on okay
so that's the that's the scale of things
okay does it make sense
so here are some um or here's the scope
of the the algorithmic audit that we
ended up doing so we looked at millions
of tweets from individual politicians
sent out in in the year 2020 and we did
kind of a fine-grained analysis of major
political parties in seven countries the
countries are canada france germany
japan spain united kingdom and united
states so we looked at all these these
countries and major politicians and or
politicians and major parties in those
countries and also for the united states
specifically we looked at 6.2 million uh
news articles that were shared so that
6.2 million shares of news articles in
the united states um and again it's the
study period was roughly april through
august 2020 okay and so here's like the
typical kind of picture we find um
here's a summary of of uh you know
algorithmic amplification for each party
um and in you know these seven countries
so um on the you know the y-axis is the
is the amplification ratio
um uh and it's called group
amplification because we look at the
party as a whole on the you know axe
axes you have various parties in
different countries so you'll recognize
some of them in the u.s it's uh house uh
democrats and house republicans some of
them democrats and uh and and some of
the republican republicans and then in
all the other countries afraid to like
sort of look at the major parties we
pulled some data on like trying to find
uh political affiliations and try to
find like all the you know politicians
that have twitter accounts
um and so um then we were able to
compute
or like look at the tweets that they
send and compute their amplification
ratio
what you're seeing is that across the
board uh politics generally gets a lift
on the algorithmic timeline so all the
amplification ratios are greater than
zero um the canada liberals are sort of
the lowest but even they get like a
little bit of a lift
and um in uh you know uh you can look at
it yourself whichever country you prefer
to look at um i think one
let's start over here one interesting
thing that we saw in germany is for
instance that the center parties so
center left sbd and center right cdu are
particularly amplified whereas the more
extreme parties the far left the linker
and the far right afd are less amplified
relative to the center parties so it's
actually again sort of like conventional
wisdom in germany at least that like the
center uh gets more uh political and or
more algorithmic amplification than the
extremes but what we're also seeing is
that across the board the um you know
the right leaning parties are faring
pretty well
um so there's generally uh you know the
uk conservatives for example and again
yes there's a slight benefit for
republicans
and uh we're seeing that across the
board um right-leaning parties are doing
a little bit better in terms of
algorithmic amplification that's also
shown by this plot in particular where
you look at
algorithmic amplification
of left-wing parties on
you know
on the x-axis compared with right-wing
parties on the y-axis so the
main diagonal would be equal
amplification
and then you see in the united states
like basically you see in all countries
except for germany
that um you you tend to be algorithmic
applications to be in the upper left
quadrant meaning that there is like a
sort of consistently higher
algorithmic application for
right-leaning parties
um we also split this up in more detail
for um you know house and
and
senate politicians by individuals so
this is where we look at individual
politicians accounts and we look at the
distribution of these amplification
ratios
um
and so the mean and standard deviation
are not that different than the us and
also not that different in in canada
but the uh republican or the
conservative parties tend to have like a
longer tail towards uh higher
amplification ratios
ask one more sure
technical question i'm still confused
about uh what this scale is like is this
a log scale
no why is zero
zero is like one to one zero one so what
is one hundred one hundred is double
one hundred and two hundred is
200 is is uh i guess uh
oh i see what you mean yeah 200 is just
uh you know uh like
uh double one hundred it's pretty good
yeah i guess
yeah i guess that's what it's yeah
okay
no no logs though it's just like
subtracting and dividing um so i guess
no it's a 200 it's just like a factor of
three okay
yeah 100 seconds or two to an effective
three four in a second uh
yeah
is there any significance to the fact
that everything was amplified
yeah i think that's that one like you
know definitely once like i think uh
interesting finding is that like
politics as a subject is sort of like or
as a as a topic on the timeline is
strongly amplified by
um the algorithm but of course this
couldn't happen across the board for all
topics right so somehow there's
something there's there's other topics
that will suffer yeah so you could you
could imagine that like
you know obviously
um politicians and news media reporting
on politics have like an interest in
like you know getting getting your
tweets seen right so you could also
imagine that these are tweets that are
particularly engaging that get sort of
ranked higher does this include like
promoted tweets and stuff like that um
so um no so promoted tweets um show up
on both the control and the treatment
group and are excluded from the study
yeah
is there control for like like
if the people in the non-contributing
treatment could spend more time on
twitter and see more things with that
like is it possible that everything
could be amplified because like it works
so well engagements that's also true
yeah so there's also um so the
uh yeah user active minutes
and so the question is like is
everything amplified for the the
algorithm timeline and it's it's true
that the just the user active minutes is
higher on the algorithmic timeline not
this much to explain like this is not
like sort of the baseline that
everything is but yes there's generally
more engagement and more scene tweets on
the overlooking timeline so that's
um so we also looked at new sources as i
said and there are um you know you can
argue about the classification of new
sources into the left meaning and right
leaving a certain controversial
classification but there are two uh
independent
media rating
organizations all sites and ad fontes
who provide media ratings so they'll
tell you like a you know a score between
right and left for different news
sources and you can agree or disagree
with this rating but it's just sort of
we ran both of these just to um give you
a sense of where things are
and here you can sort of see uh what's
happening
um
that yeah
um
pick your pick your
favorite news source here and see we'll
see where it is
so um
the
bottom graph kind of looks like they all
get amplified the same amount more or
less am i reading that how should i be
interpreting that
that's right according to the bottom
classification um there's no
you know except for like far left maybe
having
so these are not error bars these are um
just like
they're multiple news like they're
multiple media um this is the range for
the different
uh
um so this is a yeah this is not
don't think of this as like an error bar
for statistical estimate this is the
standard deviation among the new sources
right so it is true that uh the far left
uh new sources according to ad fontes
get amplified less than the far right uh
new sources according to that quantities
but yeah um
we are for example not seeing that again
here this picture that we're not seeing
that like
extreme is doing better than sarah
so um
necessarily okay
could the right be getting more engaged
yeah yeah so one one thing that
certainly could be true is that the
right is simply better at like utilizing
the algorithm timeline and it's like
creating more engaging tweets
but across areas i mean just people when
that might be not just in politics it
could
um
like i mean i wouldn't know from we
wouldn't know from this data but maybe
just overall they're more engaged on
twitter
it got more into their lives
as opposed to the more engaged with the
political issues on twitter
so
um
it's a little bit different so there's
um
what else algorithmic application
measures is
how often the tweets are seen of an
individual like if you have a politician
how often are their tweets seen right so
certainly like twitter on the whole is
like like left-leaning like there's more
democratic users than republican users
so like you probably your tweets are
also seen not just in your own political
you know sphere right
so it probably must mean that the right
is also like better able to have their
tweets engage
outside their political sort of ways for
instance by creating outreach or
something like that that's a mechanism
that would go
over like
um you know we'll create engagement
outside your own political group right
so i guess maybe i'm not understanding
your question but the way i i thought is
that
i thought the question you asked was are
republicans just more engaged than
twitter
on the algorithmic timeline maybe was
more successful
at engaging that section of the
population on twitter and increasing
them that's online which is probably
twitter's goal in the first place for
all
right so yeah and the distinction i want
to make is like are authors more
engaging or is the audience
right and that's an important difference
right so yeah it's true that if your
audience is more engaged that can lead
to amplification
um but you also have to sort of like
um you know to to really benefit from or
to really have like a lot of reach you
probably also need to engage users that
are not just like
you know in your own group
yeah
just clarification so any news source
that's to the left of zero has a real
problem
is that right in terms of getting their
message out
um yeah to the left of zero you're uh
you know you could even ask like um how
this is a good question like
um so first of all yes you're less than
zero means you're being like um
you know uh the algorithmic timeline is
not helping you it's like you know
giving you a bit of a penalty
um and it's a question of like how much
like how how significant are these
differences for like long-term
you know uh sort of uh
um you know uh benefit right like if you
imagine like there's a small penalty but
it kind of applies every day right it
compounds into like a much greater
disadvantage right and so there's sort
of a question of do you think that these
differences kind of come compound over
time
um
and so uh
yeah but i do i do think like you know
at least for uh
um
yeah i mean what you're seeing here
let's say la times compared to uh new
york post that's a huge difference of
course
it's just political tweets or
yeah like political articles yeah so
this is like shares of
political news sources
cool yeah so let's just summarize these
uh discussion points
across seven countries uh we saw that uh
right-wing parties benefit as much and
often much more than uh from algorithmic
personalization than left-wing parties
um u.s media outlets where the
right-leaning bias are amplified
marginally more
and among individual politicians uh
party membership there so there are
differences among individual politicians
but party membership is not sort of
strongly associated with application
okay
um so they're very successful individual
politicians in in across the spectrum
so again the study does not pin down uh
mechanisms behind the effect is this
kind of hodgepodge causal effect and uh
you know one mechanism that you might
sort of expect that is at play here is
that different parties utilize twitter
differently and are differently like
successful to different degrees in how
they kind of uh you know
um strategize on twitter and how they
use it for political activism
okay and what we're interested in is
kind of the relative differences among
parties and politicians
and it does not answer the question of
like whether we'd be better uh better
off with a chronological timeline for
everyone okay so this comes up a lot is
like you know does it mean we should
turn off the algorithm the timeline
maybe but we don't have the
counterfactual like what would a world
look like with only like chronological
timelines because then you could still
expect like
you can also gain the chronological
timelines right and that would lead to a
different strategy space but you might
see different effects uh in that case so
we don't have this counterfactual and
that's not the question we're we're sort
of fundamentally trying to get at
that make sense
okay cool so i'm going to get into like
kind of a complementary uh problem with
causal inference on social platforms and
this comes up a lot uh around the issue
of like user choice and and user agency
yeah sure so what is
so this is a real experiment that's
actually been run and
we've seen a lot of like
methodology
talks but
often when i see a really great being
right i often wonder like why we ran the
experiment
so i guess
if you're able to
to share and talk with us about about
this like
i guess we're measuring amplification of
this like algorithm as measured in this
way and we see lots of things
but what is twitter going to do with
this like why what's what's their end
goal with knowing this
um so i think you know
the first goal um
that was a good question so i guess the
first goal was to just
figure out like what's going on right
because like there have been all these
speculations about like who benefits
from the algorithmic timeline and one
just wanted to get some quantitative
empirical
sort of you know uh evidence out there
of what is actually happening and some
things were sort of what we expected
something were not what were expected so
i think it clarified a lot on that
um there's like uh
remains like a like a normative question
of like what do we do with this now like
does it mean we should like move away
from algorithmic curation or like you
know do should we somehow like adjust
for it right and so on um and yeah
that's those are part of what i consider
like you know uh ongoing questions right
um
so
yeah yeah one thing it makes me feel
like is and i'd love to hear your
thoughts on on this more of a comment
i'd like to hear your thoughts thoughts
on it's like i would i would guess that
what might be going on or what people
might be wanting to do is
okay i twitter the company and getting
lots of negative
feedback people say oh you're like
silencing conservative voices or you're
like you're silencing the
the like radical leftists but you're
you're silencing i run this experiment
and i say nope the data shows i'm
amplifying you all the same way like i
just
wash my hands and i'm like hey
we're treating you all kind of the same
but that's
there's still this social unrest maybe
and it feels like
i don't know
does this experiment try to like
help us address i mean i guess you just
said not not not so much but how does
that fit into the
because the picture the way i see it
fitting in is kind of like
saying well i'm not responsible for any
of this is that how i should be reading
or how what's a more optimistic read
as well um so i i think you know first
of all that's like for us to decide
right like the data like i think you
know
um these findings are out there right
like now there could be a conversation
about like you know what what would we
hold you know twitter accountable for
right and i think hopefully these things
will will make that conversation
easier or at least like provide sort of
concrete input into it you can also like
look at the communication that twitter
had around these topics and see how you
feel about this right and what they do
with it i think in the short term uh i
don't think there's anything to do with
this right i think they were just gonna
continue to build their algorithmic
timeline um i don't think they saw this
as like sort of
um
you know
relieving them of like pressure uh from
like the public on this this topic i
don't think that was the takeaway
because like in some sense these
findings are rather uncomfortable right
so
i don't think they were greatly relieved
to see this um but that's that's where
me speculating i'm not speaking on the
castles like that
could have been much worse yeah
um or
you know but yeah this is like a
conversation that now should happen
right and like you know
um we're you know
hoping that this this
the facts being out there will only fit
easily
yeah can you say a bit more about the
individual politicians part of it i
wonder whether sort of posting it at the
like quality level might hide sort of
amplification of like you know margaery
taylor breed or more oh yeah so you can
also look at the if you look at the
paper we highlighted like specific um
politicians there are certainly like
some extremely successful politicians on
twitter right like those are people that
use the likes twitter very successful
including like for instance donald trump
who's like very successful utilizing
twitter by all measures so
um
you can look at the individual like data
for these politicians like it's
available so all the data is out there
you can look up the politicians that you
want and see for those
i think very early questions just like
is it do the same conclusions
question when you group up things right
there's always like some flexibility you
have one of them first of all
you could look at daily amplification
ratios and average them out or take like
median daily thing or you could throw
all the tweets together and then do that
right so what we did is we threw all the
tweets together and then averaged
and i think when you throw all the
tweets together an average is not so
different from the media
i think what's could be more different
is if you look at like
you know if you like first compute the
daily amplification ratios and then like
mean versus media might be more
different
all right so let me let me move on we
can make a little bit more time we'll
talk about this more at the end um so
the second uh
uh sort of complementary topic i want to
talk about is the the the problem of
user agency and control on social
platforms um
and it engages with this common response
that people have to algorithm moderation
so they look at findings like these and
like oh you know we don't know what
these uh these algorithmic timelines do
we don't know what algorithm moderation
does so let's just throw give users all
sorts of controls let's give them all
sorts of settings um that they can play
with they can turn things on and off and
see you know like tailor their own
experience right
and so um twitter like many other social
platforms offers numerous such controls
um just to give you some sense you can
like personalize your push notifications
like the notifications on your cell
phone email notifications you can turn
that on or off you can also turn the
algorithmic timeline that is talked
about on or off you can go to the
reverse chronological timeline if you
want and you can also turn off like all
sorts of like filters like the quality
filter and you can have them like show
you all the tweets and not just things
they think are you know meeting some
quality bar
um that's that's something i should know
we we do know and uh it's probably even
in the paper um but it's uh it's a small
fraction
like for like most of these user
controls where it's definitely like less
than 10 percent ever look at their
settings tab and twitter and like start
tinkering with it and it's actually like
there was a i i went down that rabbit
hole once there's all sorts of settings
but it's kind of hard to get to and like
i don't even know which settings i have
enabled or disabled so
um
i might be on the reverse chronological
timeline
um so yeah but yeah so a few people like
let's say somewhere between a percent
and 10 is probably like what we're
talking about for these controls so yeah
all of these are opt they're they're
treatment by default opt in by default
and users can opt out
okay
and so um now when you're trying to
understand the causal effects of these
user agencies so what users choose to to
toggle and whatnot there's kind of um
this interesting situation that because
people can opt out
you're getting data about both treatment
and control right so you have the
default as opt-in but some people opt
out
of course by self-selection but some
people do opt out so in principle you
get the setup for kind of like
observational causal designs where you
have like both treatment and control
users and if you could somehow
deconfound uh you know the the opt out
then you would have a a causal inference
design that you could play with so
there's this question of can we estimate
the causal effect of opt-in of treatment
from observational data that we have
and uh like sort of look at it
differently
you know do randomize experiments such
as a b test anticipate the effect that
opt out has on those who chose to do so
right let's say we do like a new uh we
want to set and like create a new
setting and we run an a b test to see
who like what it does does that actually
anticipate the effect it has on people
who will then opt out right which is not
necessarily clear when you run an a b
test
so
both of these questions are really
relevant because a positive answer to uh
number one would allow you to avoid
costly and possibly also unethical
randomized experiments right if you do
something like the quality filter for
example or like an
abuse filter like something that like
filters out like abusive tweets let's
say it's not clear whether randomizing
that like doing an a b test is ethical
some people might have concerns with it
so you prefer to kind of like do an
observational design where you don't
have to become active and you just work
from uh you know the data you have
anyway
and if you had a positive answer to um
number two
then you could like more easily test the
effects that this actually has on users
right and you could more easily like
determine what's going to happen when
you set up all these controls right
good
so what we did is we wanted to know how
well uh we wanted to answer these
questions or how well uh you know uh
observational designs work for getting
at these causal effects and to do that
we used what is called the within
designs or within study comparison where
you run a randomized controlled trial or
a b test
where you set up a control group that
never receives treatments or is always
opt out
and there's a treatment group that gets
opted in that you know gets the
treatment
but they're allowed to opt out so the
treatment group can opt out so you have
to serve as one-sided compliance where
like in the treatment group people can
opt out on their own and then you run
like an observational study within the
treatment group among the exposed in the
unexposed group
okay
and this was um uh inspired by paper uh
or you know uh that i really like uh by
gordon at all from 2019 that actually
showed that in the context of targeted
advertising observational designs do
fairly poorly compared with experimental
trials uh when it comes to like
determining the effects of of ads okay
so they also use this kind of design
to show that observational methods don't
do that well
so what did we do we did four large
scale such within study comparisons of
experimental and observational causal
inference on twitter
we
looked at four different user settings
the ones i mentioned push notifications
email notifications algorithmic timeline
and quality filter
and we used four standard observational
methods to see how they work and they're
kind of like you know sort of what you i
don't have them here but it's like
inverse propensity scores and like
adjustment and like a few standard
things
and so what we've found is that like the
observational methods do very poorly
okay so on the you know bottom here the
rct is the randomized control trial uh
the y-axis is always the outcome that we
looked at in three cases just user
minutes on the platform how much time
people spend on the platform
and uh then the next four things are
just the uh observational methods
and you can see that in like uh three
out of four cases the observational
methods even got the sign wrong of the
causal effect
so you know you can see that for
instance if you turn off
or if you turn on the algorithmic
timeline this also goes back to a
question earlier if you turn on the
algorithmic timeline you see it like a
big boost in like time spent on the
platform right so the algorithmic
timeline boosts uh engagement when you
run an rct when you use any of these
observational methods based on who
chooses to see the reverse chronological
timeline you get to come away with the
impression that it decreases engagement
and why is that because people who opt
out of the algorithmic timeline
well they're uh they're really like
maybe they're really power users who
have like a very specific way of using
twitter they're really opposed to like
any kind of algorithmic intervention
they really want to see it in a certain
way and they have really strong opinions
about it so once they turn it off
they're like ah this is great and then
they spend a lot of time on twitter
right
um so
yeah and like none of these
observational designs were able to kind
of deconfound that that effect right so
they are they also come away with the
wrong impression in the case of quality
filter the sign is right but like the
magnitude is completely wrong
yeah just for completeness so rct is the
experimental data or the experiment the
randomized control trial and then
there's some like things uh
that um various observational methods
what's more important is what did we do
to try to deconfound the or like remove
confounders
um and it didn't work as you can see but
basically so the issue is is something
like this right so you have the user who
can choose to uh opt in or opt out and
you have some outcome like minutes spent
on the platform
and what we did is we adjusted for 14
available variables about the user that
could be confounding behavior okay and
we thought about what is kind of like
confounding behavior at play here the
first thing we imagined is whether or
not you're a power user right if you
have like very strong opinions about how
twitter should work like you spend a lot
of time on the platform you play around
with these settings so we adjusted for
things that tell you whether somebody is
a power user like number of minutes you
spend on twitter how old your account is
how many number of followers you have
how many people you follow etc so that's
one category of features we try to use
as as
like control variables
we also looked at things like privacy
sensitive are you turning off things
because you you know you you have your
account protected or you don't want your
tweets seen or you don't want targeted
ads things like this
and we also looked at whether your
account has some issues like it's
restricted it was blocked or whatever
right
um and none of them worked okay so in
all cases
uh you know there are too many other
things about the user that kind of give
them agency right there's too much
complexity and in this link from user to
treatment to kind of like
you know control it away okay
so um
what drives user choices is kind of
poorly described by these features that
we had right and so we weren't able to
like get a design
that works but of course this is just
like us you know there's it's impossible
to rule out that some observational
design might work right it could be that
like if you find some like extremely
clever design that might work but at
least uh spending some time on it we're
unable to to do anything that works at
all
was a problem with outliers so it's it's
certainly a problem first of all with
like the selection bias being extremely
strong right like very few people use
these controls
and so that makes the like the
confounding like much harder but like
there's a strong selection bias like you
know there's really for you to go out
and like toggle these settings a lot of
stuff has to happen and that's kind of
hard to capture with these features that
you have
that's maybe related to outliers so the
people who opt out are kind of outliers
in that sense
so yeah
so this thing is true what was the type
of randomness because a lot of times i
think that
uh if if interference is to blame for
this big difference here i think that
maybe you can uh curb the effect of
interference by doing special types of
randomization
what type of randomization was used in
the rct was it a bernoulli thing or was
it kind of a cluster based based on
entry interference or
yeah so this one um i'm less worried
about interference because um
these are relatively small rcts right
like with an algorithmic timeline we're
talking about like most users right
involved in that experiment here
um you do an a b test as you typically
do in an industry setting by just like
random user items basically
and um then like upping them in or out
right
um
and so
i i don't think interference is
like interference is not it's not a is
any way not a confounder right it would
be kind of like influencing different
experimental units
or like coordinating them in some sense
but it wouldn't
[Music]
so we came to believe that there's sort
of a catch-22 here when you try to do
these observational designs on social
platforms and so it's something it goes
something like this and you know unless
you decide if you buy it or not but this
is what i wear landed so platforms
enable user controls because human
behavior is complex and it's hard to
predict from observable features we
don't know exactly what people want so
we want to give them choice right anyone
give them autonomy because we find it
hard to to predict what they want and
what they do
but then it's exactly this difficulty of
predicting user agency and user behavior
that makes it hard to decompound
treatment and observable in an
observational study right because what
does it mean to like deconfound but it
means that somehow you can predict
treatment from user observables right
that's exactly sort of what you have to
do to decompound and that's exactly what
it means to predict user behavior from
observable features right but your
inability to do so was the reason why
you installed user controls to begin
with
so i doubt that it can sort of be done
right
i think there's kind of a this kind of
catch here
anyway so let me uh just throw out some
conclusions um you know
there are all these causal effects of
algorithmic algorithms and social
systems that we don't understand well
why is it hard to understand them
one of my main takeaways is that
methodologically it's not just a micro
problem it's also a macro problem like
it's not just like sort of something
where you can run an rct and get the
full answer from experimental data
there's also like these
uh you know these issues of like
how do these causal effects feed into
broader dynamics of change on the
platform like what are sort of the the
dynamics on the platform that bring
about long-term macroscopic changes and
that's just something hard to get at
with like a b tests right so it's a
little bit hard to approach this problem
without having any sort of like
long-term dynamic model of like how
twitter evolves
and if you wanted to have such a model
of like how twitter evolves over time
one extremely important component is
what i call microfoundations for
algorithmic decisions namely this sort
of model of like how individuals respond
uh to algorithmic decisions so if you do
some kind of update to the algorithmic
timeline how are people going to adjust
to it and that's from some fundamental
to understanding these things and
recently in a in a paper with cell stem
and mina yagarissan we
actually argued that what we currently
have when it comes to sort of these
models of individual behavior to
algorithmic decisions is not
satisfactory and this is like one
bottleneck in my opinion to
understanding all of these things
okay so specifically for this community
what are some things i would love for
you to work on first of all take any of
these things out on my first slide any
of these supposed causal stories and
come up with formal definitions
conceptual frameworks what what how do
you define it how do you measure it you
know just be sort of more rigorous about
the causal mechanisms that we think
exist on these platforms and then try to
come up with sort of empirical work or
at least designs things you would like
to see happen
to kind of test these causal mechanisms
and sort of provide sort of some
guidance to these platforms and like
what causal questions do you want to
answer as a research community and um
you know
um similar to what what you said right
what do you want to what what do we want
to measure what we want to do right
and so what uh what frameworks do we
have for like conducting experiments and
platforms and you know can we maybe like
be a little bit more systematic on like
putting forward proposals for
what these platforms should do i think
these are all great questions for like a
causal inference community like this to
to think about all right and that's all
thanks
might be out of time so
you can
yeah i'm sorry about that so let's just
talk more on the break
sorry run over